so one of the biggest developments in my
lifetime all my research life time of
over 40 years as a chemist has been that
chemists and physicists can manipulate
individual atoms sometimes they can even
see the atoms themselves I've just read
the description of very exciting
experiment from Griffith University in
Brisbane in Australia it's about imaging
a single atom in this case of ytterbium
which is also nice because it's a rare
earth element and one that we like and
in this particular experiment they had
been looking at the shadow of an atom
now if I take a ball like this and a
light source like this torch I can shine
the light onto the ball and you can see
a shadow underneath jiggling around as I
moved the torch so even if you have one
atom suspended in space and you can do
this by having a magnetic field which
will trap an atom if that particular
atom is magnetic such as ytterbium but
even if you got this if you shine the
light on it you can't see your shadow
because the wavelength of the light is
much longer than the size of the atom
and so the light just doesn't notice the
atom however if you have an atom which
can absorb light of a particular
wavelength then when it absorbs light
slightly less light will come out the
other side
so it's a sort of shadow through
absorption rather than just because it's
blocking the light so you need a very
precise wavelength of light to make sure
that the atoms absorbs it so in their
experiment they chose very carefully
which element to use and then they had
to match the frequency of the light
using a laser to make sure that the aten
absorbed the light now once the light
was absorbed
what would come out to the other side is
a diffraction pattern so it wouldn't
look like a shadow so they needed a lens
to image that onto a digital camera so
they could get the picture and to do
this they used what is called a free
nail lens now this is a really poor
example of Rennell lens it's the sort of
one that I hope keep in my pocket in
case there's something too small for me
to see but the principle is that it's a
sheet of material in this case plastic
that has concentric ridges small ridges
of plastic which focus the light Freneau
lenses are used quite frequently in
lighthouses to send a focused beam of
light out to wound ships and it's used
quite widely in physics and chemistry as
well and in this case they're used a
really special from their lens to focus
the light that had been deflected by the
atom what they saw and which has never
been seen before as well as I know is
the optical effect of a single atom of
in this case ytterbium and this is
really exciting not so much because
people are really interested in it
turbulence aim thing with molecules and
with a molecule which is not got a
spherical shape but has a definite shape
you can perhaps use this as a way of
probing the structure of the molecule
and because the molecule vibrates you
might even get information about how the
molecule is vibrating as well and the
authors of this paper are particularly
excited that you might be able to do it
with biological molecules which are
rather big and difficult to study by
other methods so it could be a real
breakthrough but like most scientific
experiments the first result is exciting
but what's really exciting is where you
can take it on afterwards